>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Anne McLean: Good evening.
Welcome. Thanks for coming
to The Printed Instrument.
Tonight's panel presentation is part
of our Technofiles miniseries
exploring how technology influences
the ways we create, perform
and experience music.
I'm Anne McLean from the
Library's music division.
It's great for us to have such a
varied audience for this tonight
where we look at this
exploding field
of 3D manufacture and
reality computing.
And, just for curiosity, how many of
people in the audience are involved
with the field in some way?
Anybody? Yeah, a few.
You know, great.
Great. This is a vast and
exponentially growing universe,
really an ecosystem of technologies.
Our speakers this evening will
be showcasing a variety of ways
in which the convergence
of this fascinating ecosystem
is creating new design
and restoration possibilities for
music creating and restoration.
We'll start out with the path
connecting the world of 3D
with music, an introduction to the
field from journalist Andrew Wheeler
and an quick, intriguing
overview from Tatjana Dzambazova
who is a technology whisperer
and Product Manager at Autodesk.
Her current project there is the
Momento program empowering artists,
scientists, curators, and
others to tell their stories
through the digitization
of capture reality.
Robert Howe is a physician and
oboist currently associated
with the PhD program at
University of Connecticut at Storrs
and is interested in the study
and replication of early versions
of the oboe and saxophone.
And, you have a treat in store.
I won't say what that is.
Eric Goldemburg is the cofounder
of MONAD Studio, a design
and research architecture
firm based in Miami.
You may have seen some of his very
sculptural instruments in the press
over the past few months.
His colleague Scott Hall on the end
will demonstrate a new 3D guitar
that they have designed together.
He's an artist, a sculptor,
also an animator and musician.
So, let me turn this over
to Andrew for a fascinating,
very state of the technology
look at music in 3D.
>> Andrew Wheeler: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Everybody hear me?
Is that good?
All right.
Let's start with a quote.
Victor Hugo wrote, "Music expresses
that which cannot be said and on
which it, on which it is
impossible to be silent."
It's a real thrill for
me to be speaking here
at the Library of Congress.
You can see there in a
nice sketch up 3D model.
This isn't the exact
building, of course, but.
My name is Andrew Wheeler.
I'm a journalist.
My beat is 3D technology.
For the last two years, I've been
covering technologies focused
around capturing reality, working
with spatial data, and using data
to interact with and
influence the physical world.
I was very pleased and
surprised to receive a phone call
from Anne McLean to help
put together this edition
of Technofiles.
I had just covered a story about
a 3D printed piezoelectric violin
from MONAD Studios that looked
like the type of instruments one
of H.R. Giger's monsters would
play as it watched the world burn.
There it is.
>> Cool.
>> Anne and I started
talking about the ways
in which these technologies
are being used
to create fascinating possibilities
in very interesting
musical projects.
We both knew the amazing work
being done at the University
of Connecticut using a combination
of computed tomography scans,
3D software, and 3D printing.
Bringing rare and sometimes
damaged instruments back
to life is an ongoing story
which you'll hear more
about from Dr. Howe.
I also just began working on,
with Autodesk on high level
concept called Reality Computing.
This is real 2016 shameless
plug happening March 8th
and 9th in San Francisco.
I knew form their amazing software
and many interesting cultural
projects including building an
online virtual tour of the
Smithsonian's collection,
that they would definitely
have something great
to contribute to this panel.
While we were brainstorming on the
phone one day, I began to think
about the relationship
between musicians
and the inventors of
musical instruments.
I think it stems from an early
fascination I have with inventors.
After all, I knew who
created the light bulb.
Bing. I learned who created the
AC motor and enabled AC power.
Bing. And, but it occurred to me
that I had never even wondered
about who invented the piano.
It was the first instrument I was
lucky enough to take lessons on.
Thanks, Dad.
Right there.
[ Laughter ]
But, I never thought
about who invented it.
Right? It's a strange
thing to think about.
So, then I, then I tried to
imagine an alternate universe
where the piano was never invented.
I thought about things like,
well, what would Beethoven's
"Moonlight Sonata"
have sounded like,
and how would it have
been delivered?
I guess maybe by harpsichord
or a string quartet.
But, then a [inaudible]
notion popped into my head.
I said, "Would Beethoven
have invented it at all?"
And, I think he would have,
but it was a striking question
that got right to the heart of an
interesting and more profound query.
At what points in history did newly
invented instruments find their way
into the hands of the
nominally talented musicians?
How did musicians of Beethoven's
caliber react to a new instrument?
How did Jimi Hendrix react
when he first got his hands
on a Fender Stratocaster?
Where are these encounters in
history, and were the inventors
of musical instruments
musicians themselves?
If we try to trace the evolution
of musical instruments back
to their origins, we sometimes
lose the trail of where they come
from and who invented them.
The same thing happens
with music itself.
For all the tones written about
musical instruments in music theory,
the origins of music are
still relatively unknown.
Now, I imagined a bunch of
early homo sapiens listening
to all the sounds of nature
and trying to imitate them.
After all, we still have
hunters using animal calls.
Except now, they aren't
required to perfect them vocally.
They can just walk out in the
woods with a Bluetooth speaker,
press play, hide, and
wait for the kill.
Takes no talent.
And, today, a talented
vocalist sells out stadiums,
but maybe back then, a
talented vocalist could mimic
and consistently attract prey.
In the beginning, did music help,
did music evolve to help us survive,
or was it a way to
communicate with gods?
Hunting rituals, harvest
rituals, spiritual rituals,
these are all possible explanations
for why music came to exist.
But, in the end, no one
knows where music comes from.
And, it turns out that the
historical relationship
between makers and musicians is
similarly difficult to trace,
but there's one fantastic
example of a maker
and musician who's virtuosity
and inventiveness changed
the world of music forever.
Pantaleon Hebenstreit was employed
as a violinist, keyboard musician,
and dance instructor in Leipzig.
He constructed, developed, and
mastered a unique, enlarged version
of the hammered dulcimer in 1697.
In 1705, he traveled to
France, and created a sensation
with his unique instrument
and playing.
Louis XIV was so astonished
by his performance
and the instrument
itself that he ordered it
to be called the Pantaleon
from then on.
This was quite an anomaly
at the time
because the hammered keyboard
instruments were not nearly
as popular as plucked
string keyboard instruments.
The harpsichord enjoyed huge
popularity in the Baroque Period,
but by 1709, an Italian harpsichord
maker named Bartolomeo Cristofori
thought it was time to
update the harpsichord.
He published a remarkable design
of what eventually would
become the pianoforte.
The keyboard design principle
was the same, but his series
of hammers striking the strings
rather than plucking them opened
up a whole new range
of possibilities
for composers and performers.
This changed, this transformed music
performance and composition forever.
And, those conceived and
born in Italy, it was,
the piano was developed over
the next four years in Germany.
The famous organ builder
Gottfried Silbermann went
through several iterations
of a grand piano with a vocal
and harsh critic named
Johann Sebastian Bach
who preferred his organs.
Now, a remarkable innovation
to the piano
by a maker named Johann Andreas
Stein caught the attention
of another musical luminary.
In a letter to his father written in
1777, Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart wrote,
"His instruments distinguish
themselves by an escapement.
Not one in a hundred makers
troubles himself about that,
but without an escapement, a
piano clatters and leaves a sound.
When one presses the keys, his
hammers fall down in the very moment
in which they bounce
against the string,
whether one holds the
key down or releases it."
In 1821, Sebastian Erard invented
the double escapement action
which incorporated a repetition
lever, also called a balancier,
that permitted repeating a note
even if the key had not yet risen
to its maximum vertical position.
This facilitated rapid
playing of repeated notes,
a musical device exploited
by Franz Liszt.
When the invention became
public as revised by Henri Herz,
the double escapement action
gradually became standard
in grand pianos and
is still incorporated
into all grand pianos
currently produced.
Still, no one knows
where music comes from,
but it is a clear example
of a musician
who invented his own
instrument, performed on it,
and inspired the creation of one
of the most popular
instruments of all time.
Tonight, we have musicians
and makers from MONAD studios
and the University of Connecticut
as well as a trained architect
and technology whisperer who
believes in the power of technology
to help people of all
disciplines and ages find, express,
and amplify their own creativity.
But, before we hear from them,
I want to take a few minutes
to introduce you to the technology
that is empowering musicians,
artists, architects,
and everyone else
to create their own
printed instruments.
All right.
Exhibit A, Concordia University
student Caleb Loughlin.
Now, Caleb, Caleb wanted
an electric guitar.
He could not afford it.
So, he leveraged the
university system,
enrolled in a technology course
to gain access to the 3D printer,
and he downloaded STL
files off the internet.
He printed four pieces of an
electric guitar body, added strings,
wiring, and a neck, and he had a
fully functioning electric guitar
made with finishing
processes in 24 hours.
He also turned it in and
got an A, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, we've a 3D
printed metallophone.
Now, metallophones are
notoriously difficult
to create even by traditional
methods.
And, this was a project that
involved research from Colombia,
MIT, Harvard, and Disney Research.
I don't really know who's
involved there, but.
The point was, they wanted to, they
wanted to create a metallophone
that was shaped like
animals, and they did it.
And, it was called, they
called it the zoolophone.
Good name, I guess.
This is probably the toughest
saxophone of all time.
The guys from Industrial
Technological Research Institute
in Taiwan 3D printed this saxophone
from Titanium which is remarkable,
and the printer they used
was originally marketed
for jewelry manufacturing, but it
actually prints to, I think it's 50,
50 microns or the width
of a human hair.
Very fine, very remarkable.
I'm not here to sort of cheerlead
3D printing all the way though.
If you actually see metal
3D printing in action,
it takes quite a lot of sort
of traditional band sawing
and machining to actually
remove it from the build plate.
So, it's not just, you
know, it's not a catch all.
It's not, not that easy.
Next, we have 3D printed
Indian tabla drums.
So, this is interesting because you
have a new technology being used
to create a very old instrument,
and this instrument traces
back to around 200 BC.
Next example is this.
These guys are here.
This is MONAD Studios
Hornucopian Dronepipe,
and this is a really
interesting example
because it shows really
what 3D software
and 3D printing can do together
which is open up the field entirely
to creating new instruments
which I thought was a very,
sort of, interesting idea.
And, that doesn't mean
you can't do it
with traditional methods,
but look at that thing.
It looks like a black wave being,
like, thrown over his shoulder.
We'll have a performance
from Scott later tonight.
Okay, god.
3D printed electric violin.
So, this guy calls
it a 3Dvarius, right?
His name is Laurant Bernadac, and
he spent years iterating in software
and 3D printing which is
another fascinating sort of use
that you could probably apply
if you're a maker of, you know,
instruments in that traditional way.
You could probably apply
that to your practice.
But, anyway, so he designed it over
and over, and what his goal was
to make it sound like a Stradivarius
which is quite a lofty
and insane goal.
And, I heard the sound of it.
Not at all like a Stradivarius.
[ Laughter ]
But, I applaud him for
trying and, you know,
wish him luck in the future.
I don't know what else
to say about it.
But, it's very cool, and this is
printed with stereolithography.
And, this is a, I'm sure most of
you are familiar with 3D printing
as fuse deposition modeling which
is the thing that sort of looks
like a automated glue gun.
Just sort of spits out
plastic in what looks
like a little toaster oven.
By the way, the technology
in there is all the same.
You got to a 3D printing show, and
it basically looks like you have,
you know, the same technology in
the Witness Protection Program.
They all have different outsides.
Okay. So, in conclusion, we may
not know where music comes from,
but I hope after tonight, we'll have
a better idea of where it's going.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tatjana Dzambazova: So, my
father was a composer, is still,
and [inaudible] orchestra.
And, I grew up in a house where
we had pretty much every single
instrument that I never played.
So, tonight, I will not
talk about any of that.
I'll leave the music to those
who understand better than me.
But, I will talk about what
I understand quite well
which is technology.
And, we'll start with a video
that is quite high level
and very visionary to kind
of get things started.
[ Music ]
I think that the divide
between what's analog
and what's digital
is starting to merge.
Our physical world is so
unimaginably rich in texture
and in depth, but until very
recently, our digital experiences
for the most part, have been limited
to flat, 2D impressions of reality.
Today, innovative technologies
like 3D printing, web go,
virtual reality, and augmented
reality are all redefining the ways
we can experience and
recreate the world around us.
So, what do all of these
revolutionary technologies have
in common?
They all require high
quality, 3D digital models.
What does it take to
make a 3D digital model?
You can create a model from scratch,
geometrically constructing it
by extruding and revolving
with nerves,
meshes, [inaudible] and solids.
It's a laborious process
requiring complex software
and high end knowledge.
Alternatively, you can capture
the analog world as it exists.
This can be achieved with
specialized 3D scanners,
but this type of hardware
is prohibitively expensive
and also requires immense
technical expertise.
Every day, technology's becoming
more accessible and easier to use,
but the difficulty of generating
high quality 3D assets has kept this
trend out of the world
of 3D, until now.
A new process called photogrammetry
utilizes state of the art algorithms
to convert regular to default
as directly into 3D data.
With smart sensors that are
now ubiquitous and new software
that is exceptionally easy
to use, anyone with access
to a modern smartphone or
a camera can now capture
and create a high quality,
ready to use 3D digital model.
What stories can be told when we can
all digitize the world around us?
For artists, being able
to easily capture, modify,
and recreate physical assets opens
up a universe of possibilities.
When we can sculpt any object,
environment, or living thing,
the entire world becomes
clay in our hands.
For marine biologists, it's helping
them better understand the world's
everchanging oceans.
For the first time ever,
using photogrammetry,
scientist can measure
coral resistance
with astonishing accuracy.
Not only does this enable
us to document the state
of existing corals, but
with repeated scanning,
we can actually observe ecological
changes as they happen over time.
The Buddhas of Bamiyan
in Afghanistan were
glorious sketches carved
into a massive cliff
over 1000 years ago.
In 2001, they were destroyed
forever when they were dynamited
in an act of religious extremism.
Like so many times in our
history, an invaluable piece
of human heritage had been lost.
Except, this time, we decided
to search for the lost sketches
in a place that previously
nobody would have ever thought
to look, the web.
Between Facebook, Flickr, and
Google images, there are thousands
of photos of the Bamiyan
Buddhas taken by tourists
through the decades and from
almost every possible angle.
Using photogrammetry and hundreds
of these crowd sourced images,
the team was able to digitally
reconstruct the Bamiyan Buddhas
in a gloriously detailed 3D replica.
One which now celebrates
the story of humanity,
of all of us together preserving a
vital legacy for future generations.
In the near future, we will be
able to digitize our entire planet
as it exists in every moment.
This four dimensional impression
of our world will enable future
generations to literally scroll back
and see what was really going
on in this particular part
of the world at that time.
We'll digitize ourselves
as well, giving our great,
great grandchildren the chance
to see us the way we were
when we were their age.
By being able to better
document our achievements as well
as our mistakes, we will help
new generations build a future
for themselves that
we can't even imagine.
Some stories are simply
too big to be told
by one person or one
group of people.
From passive listeners to active
participants, we all have the power
to take initiative in this frontier
of democratized capturing creation.
We're able to connect dots
differently to find deeper meanings
in the patterns that
emerge and, consequently,
we're able to begin
asking better questions.
These new stories can be experienced
differently in all [inaudible] ways
across time, across
geography, across culture,
and most importantly, these
stories will mean so much more to us
because we were part of their
creation in the first place.
[ Music ]
And, to show you that
this is not just a vision,
let's take a look at
couple of projects.
This is the common raven, the most
intelligent bird on the planet,
and lately he's having a lot of fun.
He's basically focusing on the
desert tortoises, and unfortunately
and sadly, these images
are very often to be seen
in the California desert.
The raven attacks the baby
tortoises, and basically,
we're down to one last
generation of tortoises.
If we don't save this generation,
this species in the
California desert will be gone.
Why is this happening?
Because the ravens have
explosion of population.
They're about 50 times
more than they used to be.
And, who is guilty?
Of course, we humans.
We create a lot of garbage.
We destroy the habitat.
We create a lot of imbalance.
So, who will fix the problem?
The two people who actually
have a very good idea.
Using technology, they thought
they can outsmart the ravens.
Those two people are Dr.
William Boarman and Tim Shields
from Hardshell Labs, and they said,
"Let's make a technotortoise
[phonetic]."
Basically, making fake tortoises,
placing them in the desert,
and teaching the ravens something
better than what he does.
How they do that?
They simply leverage the new sensors
which is basically super high
quality cameras on your phone
or just any pocket camera.
They take bunch of pictures
of real tortoise shells,
and then using the software that
I'm helping them with, Momento,
they basically create
3D digital models.
And then, they print.
These are just some print replicas.
Which one is the true one,
and which one is the fake?
Probably it's not easy to tell.
And then, the idea is to put
the [inaudible] on top of each
of the turtles so that when a
raven attacks, it sprays something
like a pepper spray
that will not kill him.
It's biodegradable.
But being smart as a raven
is, after three attempts,
he will say, "I'm out of here, man.
I'm not going to touch
this thing anymore."
So, that's really their idea.
They opened a Kickstarter campaign
because they're raising money
not only to do this but also
to make the ravens,
the tortoises move
like with a little
[inaudible] robots,
etc. This is the very reason why
I left architecture 15 years ago
and then moved to be in technologies
because I really wanted to be a part
of a team that creates technologies
to enable small players
to play the big game.
Bill and Tim do not have much money.
A tortoise researcher, you can
imagine how much that is paid
or how much funding there is there.
But, leveraging technology, they
are inventing the conservation
preservation 2.0, and
this is really beautiful.
The next story is about Dr. Louis
Leakey who is the third generation
of the famous Leakey family
that for three generations
and six decades has been
operating in Tanzania and Kenya,
basically telling the
story of the human origins.
They have found thousands
and thousands of fossils
of the first hominids and
humans and animals and tools.
And, for years, they wanted
to share their knowledge
with the world, but how?
How many people go to Kenya?
They are in the Museum of
Nairobi, but it's not easy
for other scientists, let alone
for teachers who teach that,
or for aficionados just to see it.
So, Louise was at TED,
and she saw a photo booth
in which we were demonstrating
how you can use normal photography
to create 3D digital
models of the fossils.
And, she loved it, and she started
testing, and she learned how
to create beautiful, 3D
digital models out of the photos
that with very small means, and
she herself and couple of members
of her team are doing to
digitize the collection.
And, they started putting
the collection online.
The site is called
africanfossils.org,
and you can go there and you
can basically start exploring.
If you're a scientist, you
can search by a fossil number.
If you're just a teacher,
you can start looking,
showing the kids how it looks like.
And, you know, instead of asking
kids to open a book at second page
and learn about something, they
can actually digitally touch it,
explore it, look in the detail,
compare them, etc. Louise
and her team are also allowing you
to download the 3D digital model
so that if you have a 3D printer
in the school or download patterns
that are cardboard patterns
to assemble them like a puzzle
into the different skulls.
This is an experiential learning.
Instead of just from a book,
you actually can touch it,
you can feel it, you can compare,
wow, this guy had a bigger brain.
This guy was, you know.
So, she is, in a way,
not only archiving
and salvaging what her family has
been doing for three generations,
but also introducing a new form
of a much more interesting
way to educate.
The next story is about, the
color's a little bit faded out here,
but it's a museum in Sweden, a
Mediterranean museum in Sweden.
They wanted to use tech to
make kind of new experiences
about upcoming Egyptian collection
that they were going to open.
So, they had this [inaudible]
that they gave to us,
and basically what the team did
was made the tomography or CAT scan
of the mummified body
and then the rest
of the sarcophagi and
the cartonnage.
We just took photography out of.
In the end, we ended up with a 3D
digital models of the mummified body
of the first, the cartonnage of the
first sarcophagi and the second.
Basically, a 3D digitized
replica of the entire artifact.
And, why did we do that?
Well, they worked with
Interspectral,
a company that really
specializes on these new type
of interactive experiences on a
table that actually was placed just
in front of the glass behind which
the mummy was kind of dusting.
And, this table enables you
to basically digitally unwrap
the mummy, slice through it,
look into the finest details
of every of the hieroglyphs
or of the pearls, etc. And,
obviously, because it was 3D
and digitized, we could also
make 3D printed replicas
out of the sarcophagus.
But, there was something
even more interesting.
While they did the CAT
scanning of the mummified body,
they found 120 hidden amulets
under the wrappings of the mummy.
Without needing to unwrap them,
we could actually print them
and see them in real life.
We actually printed the
negative and then they cast it
in bronze down the amulets.
Quite amazing, right?
So, these guys are introducing
new experiences and tactile.
You have a new digital touching, and
then you have touching of something
that you are not ever
going to be allowed
to touch unless you
unwrap the mummy, right?
The next one is closest to you.
Two years ago, we started a
project with the Smithsonian.
Needless to say, biggest
collection of museum in the world.
90 museums, 137 million objects.
Catastrophe, right?
And, for those of you who like going
to museum like me, you only see 2%
because there is no space.
You don't get enough buildings
here, so a lot of the stuff is
in storage rooms, etc. And, a
very smart, young energized team
in the Smithsonian decided there
must be a solution to this.
How can we show the collections
that we have to the whole world,
not only those who come
to museums and see 2%,
but everything to everybody?
And, thus, how to engage
the kids of today who think
that computers are everything,
and they find that, you know,
museums are kind of archaic
institutions, in their opinion.
So, this team started
digitizing some iconic pieces
from different museums,
and at that moment, we met.
And we conceptualized together a
solution that will bring museums
on the cloud, accessible
to everybody online.
And, this was a prototype
that we together did.
It's called the Smithsonian
X 3D in which we started
with about 20 iconic objects
from as small as a bit
to as big as a supernova remnant.
And, basically, the idea
was to put them in a browser
and let people explore it while also
following what the curators have
spent their entire lives
with those artifacts can tell
about those subjects.
We have a couple of rules.
We wanted the objects to be
as beautiful as in real life
and not as in second life.
Then, we wanted to offer some
tools that scientists can use,
that curators can do for
researching, for comparing,
for measuring, sectioning through.
Some objects are more interesting
with what's happening
inside that outside.
Profiling, then allow curators
to define hot zones and hot spots
to get additional explanation
and create tours on their own.
So, here is a little video
that I made, but you're welcome
to explore it on your own.
It's called Smithsonian X 3D.
This is one of the two life
masks from around Lincoln.
As you can see, you
can change the setting.
You can see it in 3D.
you can explore it.
Imagine you're a teacher.
You're teaching about the mammoth.
Instead of saying, "Open
book on page 130," you say,
"Download the Smithsonian digital
mammoth and tell me how big was it.
How tall was his leg?"
etc. And, but also we wanted to use
this artifacts to make some fun,
to make art, for example, a sticker
for a t-shirt out of the mammoth,
etc. This is my favorite project
because this is a single cosmic
Buddha, unique in the world,
and the relief was so shallow that
it was not possible to read it.
When we showed the curator
that he actually can make
the relief deeper just
because it was digitized,
he was sold because this is
where you see how technology today
can help you research a little bit
deeper, a little bit different
and present and explain
about our past achievements
or about details
of our inventions in
a new, different way.
Obviously, again, because
everything is in 3D,
researchers are using 3D printouts
in order not to touch the originals,
but also using them for education.
We even use some other software
that's not for 3D printing
but for cardboard making.
One to 3D make, to make one on one
crates for different objects just
by making the negative of the
object and then making the crate.
These, I personally made.
It was, it costed me about $70 and
three hours of my time versus couple
of thousand dollars of a crate,
for shipping, and for archiving,
etc. And, this is all possible with
this new ways of either digitizing
or designing or making things.
Smithsonian definitely paved the
path of the future of the museums,
the future of experience, the future
of education, the future
of curation.
So, this all sounds very
simple and easy, but actually,
when all of these pioneers
started to do that,
realizing the opportunities of the
technologies, it was very difficult.
They had to learn super many
software that they, as curators
or scientists, was like,
I'm not mechanical engineer.
I cannot use this.
it was a very difficult
process and very complex.
These led us to the idea by
working with these people
who knew what they wanted to create
a product that we call Momento
that basically enables you, either
from photos or from laser scans
or structuralized scanners,
in the most easy way.
This is shown with photos.
You just take bunch of photos.
You load them in the software, and
then the software converts them
into a 3D digital replica.
At first, when you receive it,
you receive something like this,
and you say, wait a second.
I took photos of the
sculpture, and I got that mess.
But, actually, the
sculpture is in the middle.
Obviously, the photos did
not know how far to go,
so they were just capturing
everything.
But, then we made bunch of
[inaudible] really easily.
Clean up the environment, then
close the holes if you wanted to.
You print it to be, so it's like a
3D photoshop, making 3D photography.
But then, that photography can be
turned into the real world back
to CNC, to 3D printing, etc.
So, why does this matter to you,
and how does this relate to anything
that you came for here tonight?
Well, all of these pioneers have
recognized new opportunities opened
with advanced technology.
In particular, with
the following trends.
The trends of ubiquitous
sensors, the trends of new ways
to fabrication, to
CNC, to 3D printing,
and trends of the powerful 3D web
and augmented through anything,
mixed reality, smart
mobiles, etc. So,
what do I mean by ubiquitous
sensors?
Well, we're live in
an age of sensors.
Sensors are any photo camera
on your phone, on your iPad,
on your pocket camera, big camera.
Something that used to cost
couple of thousand dollar camera,
now that quality sensor,
you have it on every phone
that you guys have here in the room.
But, there are also
other types of sensors.
There is something that
we call structure light
which is basically photo with a
projector, and then laser scanners.
They vary in price and, but
they all have the same trend.
They become cheaper and better.
So, they become ubiquitous.
They become accessible.
The second trend is about
the new way of making things,
the new fabrication methods.
For a long time now,
digital fabrication methods
have exchanged the analog method
of cutting and chopping, etc. We
have now what we call CNC machines,
Computer Numerically
Controlled machines
that usually require a digital
file to make something awesome.
And, the one that is most famous
is obviously the additive one,
the 3D printers.
And 3D printers are not interesting
because hey you can buy them
and put them at home
and make, you know,
plastic ducks and iPhone covers.
How many of those can we make?
But, it's more interesting
because you don't need
knowledge to use them.
They're affordable.
They allow for distributive
manufacturing,
meaning that they can be in
many places in the world,
and instead of I design something.
I want to make it.
I have to order it from China,
from America, from wherever.
It can be locally made.
But, most interestingly about
all the different effects
in 3D printing is that
complexity comes for free.
A printer does not care
if you're printing a box
or if you're printing
something super beautiful,
just like what you will
see later being done.
And, this, now, leads us to
the effect that to understand
that until now, we
have been designing
for subtractive manufacturing
method.
Now, we have the opportunity
to revisit how we design things
and to start, maybe, designing with
algorithms and leveraging the fact
that this 3D printers can
print very complex structures.
So, something like a bike
stand can be much, much lighter
and much sturdier if it is make
out of [inaudible] structure,
but that was not possible
to be done until now
in the ways we were manufacturing.
This has a huge impact
on the world of design.
And, the last trend that
I spoke of is the 3D web,
the web go technologies, the
oculus rifts in Microsoft Lenses,
and all of these new ways allow
us to experience in a new way.
So, to conclude, scientists,
researchers, curators, doctors,
designers, artists of all kinds,
they will have much
more fun in the future.
They will be able to push
their professions to new limits
that they never thought they
could do, and this concept
of which we call rip, fix, burn.
Rip the reality.
Fix it, mix it, change it, and then
reburn it back with 3D printing
or CNC or rip, fix, learn.
Educate in a new way.
Teach in a new way.
Experience in a new way.
I believe will affect
every aspect of our lives.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Howe: Well, thank
you for your attention.
I'm Robert Howe, and it's a
great pleasure to be invited here
on behalf of my colleagues in the
UConn Digital Musicology Group.
Before I go any further, I'd like to
thank the people who have helped us
with this project, and besides those
many people who are listed here,
I have to also mention Greg
Case and Jeffrey Emerich
of the Coast Guard Band and
Ian Jackson of the University
of Connecticut for their help
in play testing the
mouthpieces that we created.
This is my second appearance
here at the Madison Building.
The first being at the American
Musical Instrument Society meeting
six years ago.
Then, as now, my talk
concerned the study
of antique woodwind instruments.
That time, I was talking about the
baroque oboe, and now I'm talking
about the early saxophone.
And, the relearning of the
techniques necessary to play them
in the fashion of their time.
This is a whole field
of music study,
the so-called period music movement,
and it's one that I'm very involved
in as a, sort of, an outside
talented amateur and student.
So, I'm interested in woodwinds,
and a woodwind is typically
blown with a reed.
The mouthpiece and the
attached reed are the key
to understanding the
woodwind, how it sounds,
how it behaves acoustically
and musically.
For the reasons shown on this slide,
period woodwind artists have been
hampered by the lack of specimens
with a lack of data
on the construction
of early mouthpieces and reeds.
For 40 years now, we've been
reviving the baroque oboe,
but we still are not completely
sure, for example, how the players
of the day made their reeds.
Looking at the earliest saxophones,
we have a substantial number
of specimens, at least 100
that are in playing condition.
In my own efforts playing
these instruments,
one notes a very profound
of the mouthpiece.
In these two specimens,
the tenor plays very well
with the original mouthpiece
which we're fortunate to have.
But, no modern mouthpiece,
even those that are said
to copy Sax's designs,
have been suitable.
So, I wrote to the guy
that sells the mouthpieces
that he says are copied after Sax's
designs, and he says, "Oh, no.
I've never seen one, but this
is what I think they should be
from what I've read."
Well, he's doing the best he can,
but, you know, as for the alto
on the right, I have found no modern
mouthpiece which permits this horn
to play at a suitable pitch that
would have been at the time,
nor one that permits it to
play in tune with itself.
And, the antique mouthpiece that
I received with it which is not
of Sax's manufacture doesn't do
any better than the modern one.
And, this tells us that
Sax had some unique element
in his mouthpiece design
which has not been carried
down to modern times or elements.
The surviving sax, saxophone
mouthpieces are very few
and have not been systematically
studies.
Being extremely fortunate
to have access
to the tenor saxophone
mouthpiece and the instrument
with which it was built, I wondered
if I could determine
the characteristics
that make it successful.
If I could replicate it, and
if one could then apply those
characteristics to other
species of saxophone,
soprano, alto, and baritone.
But, first, I wondered, is
this a legitimate exercise.
Is it correct to derive mouthpieces
for other species from the tenor?
And, going back to first sources,
Sax's 1846 patent for the Saxophone,
displays the mouthpiece
very prominently.
It's shown thrice on the
document with the mouthpieces
on the two specimens
that are sketched being
essentially identical.
This one on the left is
what we would call, now,
a baritone saxophone, and the form
on the right never made
it into production.
But, he answered my question
as to whether it was legitimate
to scale them up and scale them
down in his own patent application.
There's the answer.
Now, as a physician by day, I deal
with medical imaging every day
of my life, and I have an
interest in ultrasound and CT.
And, I've been using CT to look
at the fine details of
woodwind manufacture.
Micro CT, that is to say CT with
pixel sizes in the micrometer range,
1/1000 of a millimeter, allows us
to study objects with
extreme precision.
And, of course, any CT allows us
to view the anatomy of an object
from any point of view
without taking measurements
and without doing anything that
might damage the instruments.
And, just to clarify for everyone,
what's the difference
between x-ray and CT?
The gentleman on the left is
being subject to an x-ray.
There's a plate behind him
and a beam is going to go
through his chest and
expose the plate.
It's instantaneous, but it only
gives you a 2D object, oh, 2D view.
The woman on the right who's
going to be subject to a CT,
that torus has beams, has
beams that are going to come
from all directions around her,
and then there are
detectors on the other side.
So, just as you were displaying here
with the cameras, we'll get a myriad
of views which are then summed by
the computer to create a 3D file
that can be viewed from
any desired object.
So, to do the work on the saxophone,
I needed an expert in micro CT,
and I was fortunate to find Dr. Sina
Shahbazmohamadi who is the director,
now, if imaging at the Chase Labs
at University of Connecticut.
And, my advisor, Richard Bass,
helped out also from musicological
and administrative points of view.
Then, we were very,
we are very fortunate
that Sina's wife Zahra
[assumed spelling],
who is also a mechanical engineer,
was able to become our consultant
for additive manufacture.
We did some initial work on
the instruments that Richard
and I are holding, the curved
English horn and the recorder,
and then you can see that Dr.
Shahbazmohamadi is holding the tenor
saxophone in question with one
of our replicated mouthpieces.
In his, in his micro CT work,
Sina used the standard industrial
equipment at two labs a UConn,
and he performed our
data manipulation.
Here to show you how
that's done on the right.
On the leftmost part of the
image, there's the x-ray source.
Then, in the middle, that
orange yellow thing is the tie
on an oboe reed, and
it's in a holder
which will rotate 1/1000th
of a circle.
Then, the ten second
exposure's taken.
Then, it moves 1/1000th of a circle
so as to get that myriad of views
that we need for the CT analysis.
And then, the detector
is on the far right.
Sina and I were, then,
able to do manipulation
and clarification of the data.
We benefitted very much
from the advantages
of micro computed tomography,
and the last one, of course,
the last two are the ones that are
of substantial importance to us
in a saxophone mouthpiece.
The internal geometry is
notoriously difficult to measure,
and we could translate
it into some form
for added manufacture
of computerized milling.
The disadvantages of micro CT,
however are not, are not trivial.
The greatest one being
the limited specimen size.
The largest specimen that
our machine can handle is ten
centimeters in dimension, so we
are obliged, for something as small
as a saxophone mouthpiece,
to take two views and then
to stitch them digitally.
Y'all should take this for granted.
Here's how additive
manufacture works.
You take a CAD file.
You create another file out of
that, and you lay it down in layers.
It's the creation of an object by
applying thin layer of material,
one atop the other, rather
than removing material
from a larger block.
So, instead of taking a piece
of stone and removing everything
that doesn't look like a
bunny, you take nothing
and you add all the stuff
that does look like a bunny,
and you end up with a bunny.
But, the important thing's that
it permits extreme precision
and unlimited numbers of copies.
This is, this is a
low complexity machine
at work, probably making a bunny.
So, here's the foot joint on
the left of an antique recorder
by Cahuzac [assumed spelling] circa
1750, and then there's a copy made
by a professional recorder maker,
and then there's four identical
copies that Sina and I made.
My daughter, Katherine, is
going to pass some of those
around for you all to inspect.
Please understand that the joints
she's passing around are early,
early iterations and that our
quality control has gotten better.
But, they'll give you an
idea of what they are.
The four on the right are, you know,
they were produced just as easily
as making one would have been.
It's just a matter of telling
the machine how many times
to lay it down, and you can
make it, you can take a plate
and make 100 at time if you want.
In our first presentation of
this project, Sina demonstrated
that the micro CT and additive
manufacture copies were actually
closer to the original
than the copies made
by a professional recorder maker.
And, he also demonstrated, by taking
CTs of our copies and comparing them
to CTs of the original and of the
artisan copy, that the dimensions
that are hardest to
take by a craftsman,
particularly the internal
diameters of tone holes
where you're measuring
at a deep level.
Those showed the greatest
advantage for micro CT.
So, the method had an error of
less than 1% in all dimensions.
It was within the error
of my measurements.
So, here's the anatomy of
a saxophone mouthpiece,
and look particularly at
the upper one on the left.
It shows the tip opening.
That's the place where the air goes
through between the
reed and the mouthpiece.
And, the reed has its excursion
between this position you see
and the tip of the mouthpiece.
If the reed is too soft,
the player's breath will just blow
it shut and no sound will issue.
Look on the lower one
at the lay and rails.
You see those slender pieces there?
Here's the mouthpiece from b
flat tenor saxophone 39116,
and you see the surface
rendering that we took by CT.
Look at the detail
that CT gives you.
You can even see, you can
compare the color on here
where the grain differs and
that's picked up on the CT.
Taking slices of CT
is called a tomogram.
It's a leftover term from
traditional radiology,
and here's some transverse tomograms
from the saxophone mouthpiece.
So, in the center of that
baffle area that I showed you
between the two rails, you can see
that the inside, it's not spherical.
It's not circular.
It has a fairly complicated,
handmade shape.
Whereas, down in the shank
that goes on to the neck
of the instrument, it's
perfectly circular.
And, the join between those two,
those two chambers,
is fairly abrupt.
We could also see, and I don't
show it here, at the very bottom,
take the left image, the piece on
the left, the tongue sticking up.
At the very tip of that,
there's a complicated anatomy
of several curve's intersection
which is probably from the way
that it's hand fabricated
that hasn't been recognized
by modern makers, and
I think may be part
of the what is unique
about the sax design.
I spent, I spent a few hours wasting
time trying to take measurements
by hand, and as you can see, you can
get very, very fine measurements,
but you can see the very, very
tedious to do that and to turn
that into a reamer to create
a mouthpiece would be of,
would be just prohibitively
difficult to get accurate,
accurate milling and
creation, unless, of course,
you use the digital method.
So, it made more sense to us to go
directly to a computerized 3D source
such as additive manufacture.
So, Zahra made a rough copy for
us, and it's not shown here.
And, we were very pleased
by its utility.
It played okay, so we did
just like you were saying.
I needed a, I was overseas
and I needed it.
So, we sent the data to a company in
France, and then they overnighted it
to me in Brussels, and a had a
working copy like 16 hours later.
A day and 16 hours later.
It just took no time at all,
and the son of a gun plays.
It plays wonderfully.
It plays better than the
original which suggests
that there may be either a
bias on my part or a matter
of the material that's being used.
Perhaps the latter.
So, very pleased by
these initial results.
I measured the bore of each species
of Adolf Sax's saxophone, soprano,
alto, tenor, and baritone.
And, using tenor as 100%, I scaled
the mouthpiece designs up and down
to the relative bore sizes, and we
created a family of mouthpieces.
Katie's going to pass around
some of the soprano mouthpieces,
just showing how I made
them at 76%, 78%, 72%.
We tried different sizes
until we found the one
that gave us the best acoustical
results on the instrument.
When you, when you study this,
don't only, don't just look at them.
Also, feel them, and you'll feel
one of the flaws for this method,
and we'll talk about
that in a moment.
So, how do they play?
You will ask, how do they play?
Well, I have here Adolf Sax's
soprano 32194 from 1866,
and I'm going to play it first
with a modern mouthpiece and then
with our UConn mouthpiece.
And, I ask you to pardon
my not having warmed up.
This is the treat to which
Anne referred, and the treat is
that I'll only play
it for a short time.
[ Laughter ]
Now, this is a [inaudible]
mouthpiece from the 1990s.
Yeah, this is the original
instrument.
1866. Not quite in
perfect condition.
It has, you'll hear
there's a few leaks on it,
but enough to make the point.
[ Music ]
There's a modern mouthpiece in it.
And with our copy here.
This is very, the ligature
doesn't quite fit,
so it's a fussy thing to get right.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
The other one's called ebonite.
It's a plastic.
It's been used for
mouthpieces for 130 years.
When that material became available,
manufacturers abandoned
wooden mouthpieces overnight
because it's stable, and
the mouthpiece, you know,
is the part that's in your mouth
and it warps and cracks and chips.
And, a stable one's a good thing.
[ Music ]
Now, that's not quite on par.
So, if you'll pardon the
left hand being [inaudible].
[ Music ]
No woodwind player's
ever happy with his reed.
[ Music ]
It's a softer, more covered mellow
sound than a modern would give,
and we were very fortunate
to have the cooperation
from our performance people at UConn
who gave up a week out their lives
to work intensively on this.
I'm going to start this now.
I hope it's not too loud, but this
is the UConn faculty saxophonists
and a graduate student with
yours truly playing tenor.
Just for 20 seconds
of quartet from 1856.
>> We touch one, and it's like,
you know, an unbelievable honor.
[ Music ]
So, that's what they sound like.
So, the soprano worked fine.
The problematic alto that I
showed you before was tamed
by the mouthpiece.
It plays in tune, and it played at
the correct pitches, saxes time,
and I had a slide showing that.
So, here's the family we created,
and this is a fellow that I just met
at a music shop playing
on one of my mouthpieces.
And, this is the problematic alto
with the mouthpiece that I got
with it which doesn't work, but
it plays beautifully at A438
with the UConn mouthpiece.
The tenor, as I say, plays as
well or better with the replica
than with the original, and the
baritone plays just magnificently.
It sounded great.
Now, there are differences, and this
is why we do period music is to find
out what is different and learn
from it and then be able to do it.
The tip opening on the sax original.
Go back to that slide I showed you
of saxophone mouthpiece anatomy.
The tip opening is very, very small,
about 1/3 of what it is
on modern mouthpieces.
This requires a harder reed,
so it doesn't just flap shut.
And, a harder reed reduces the
responsiveness of the instrument,
but it enriches their sound.
So, the tenor and the soprano
also required narrower reeds
than are sold today.
And, I was fortunate to have a box
of specialty narrow tenor
saxophone reeds in my basement.
I don't know why I
had them, but I did.
You know, if you live long enough,
everything you have will
eventually become useful.
And, b flat clarinet reeds
turned out to work fine
on the soprano mouthpiece.
Now, the period saxophone
world is a small one,
and as word of our work got out,
new mouthpieces came to the fore.
And so, I got some measurements
just with calipers, not with CT.
I was very pleased to find that
our measurements for the alto
and the baritone agreed within a
few percent with Sax's original.
For the soprano, however, Sax
didn't follow his own advice.
He didn't simply scale
down, scale down the bass.
He made a squat, wide mouthpiece
which, of course, works wonderfully
and which is more of a model
for how things are done today.
But, it was interesting.
Although, you can see my dimensions
very, very much from the original,
the volume contained within it
is only 3% different, and that's,
that's a major factor to
the intonation and pitch
of the instrument is the
volume within the mouthpiece.
So, Sax deviated from
his own design,
but his own design would have
worked perfectly well, we think.
There are flaws in the method, and
if you've had those mouthpieces
in your hands that I'm passing
around, you'll find on the lay,
on the rails, there's
little irregularities.
And, this is, this is stepping
artifact, with additive manufacture,
each time you have a layer end
and the next one continues,
it's like little stepping stone,
and so it's a little bit imperfect.
Also, if you saw on the
recorder foot joints
that we were passing around,
they're kind of rough and scaly
on the outside, and that's
a so-called grain artifact
that distorts surfaces.
We also find that one external
surface, the one that's
on the manufacturing
plate, is perfectly smooth,
and the other ones have these
potential for artifacts.
And, one that's important, I think,
is that copying something
propagates any unrecognized changes
that have happened in it, and just
something we have to do carefully.
We've considered the numerous
directions for further research
in this, but right now,
we're limiting ourselves
to improving the mouthpiece
manufacture
and to getting our
current work published.
There's only, you know,
there's only 24 hours in a day,
and we all have, we
all have business.
But, it's interesting to find
that there is a physician
out in Minnesota who has done
CT on a Stradivarius and broken
down the images into individual
parts, and you can get a copy
of this violin made by CNC milling
which is actually put together
by luthiers, not by
gynecologists or radiologists.
And, they play perfectly well.
There is substantial work being
done on string instruments which is,
of course, where the money
is in musical instruments,
and in some of the European labs.
We are very fortunate that our
work was published in our journal
of first choice before we
were even finished with it,
and I think this is in large part
because this is really something
that required a university,
not a conservatory
and not a technical institute.
You needed to have music
people and you needed
to have engineering
to have imaging people
to make this work.
So, it's part of the
bringing together, I think,
intellectually, of the project.
So, in summary, we use micro
CT to create a data file
of an Adolf Sax tenor
saxophone mouthpiece.
We modified the data
to create a family
of working mouthpieces
by additive manufacture.
The method works, and with
refinement, we will produce all
of the mouthpieces we need,
perhaps using CNC milling rather
than additive manufacture.
Groucho Marx, excuse me,
told us that "it ain't
over 'til the fat lady sings."
The lady in the upper right is
singing, and my talk is over.
I thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
Oh, there's two, there's two places
you can find a longer playing
of the saxophone quartet.
If you go to Google and google
"UConn today sax mouthpiece".
Hits one and three are two separate
radio reports that we've had
on this work that have the
quartet playing at length.
They're really nice.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Goldemberg: Hi.
I'm the fat lady.
[ Laughter ]
My name is Eric Goldemberg
from MONAD studio,
and one of two components
of MONAD studio
that I want is Veronica Zalcberg
who's in Miami with our two kids.
And, I'm very grateful
and honored to be here
at the Library of Congress.
Thank you, Andrew.
Thank you, Anne for the [inaudible]
and also for inviting Scott,
and I would like to show you what,
in a way, I'm going to focus,
of course, on the music instruments
and sonic installations
that were done recently.
There's a whole, a very long
trajectory leading to this,
and still myself trying
to understand why we end
up designing music instrument
but I am an architect.
And, MONAD Studio is
an architecture firm.
That's mostly experimental
projects derived from competition
and digital design,
and I'm also professor
of architecture at FIU in Miami.
And, but let's get started.
So, in a way, just to
put it simply, if I can.
I want to show you why I think
what I, what we've been doing
and these trajectory's about.
It's about bringing the
surfaces of architecture
that usually surround us, but the
certain space that they define
and we are smaller entity in
that space, as many as we may be.
And, I just wanted to bring
all those surfaces much closer
to the body.
I think this whole presentation is
about that and the whole big part
of the motivation of doing music
instruments is more like going
into body prosthesis, prosthetics
on my part rather than the music
which I leave to my great partner
Scott here who's also a designer.
And so, this is the cover of a
book that I've done recently called
"Pulsation in Architecture",
and it's my research
on a certain obsession
about rhythmicity or rhythm
in architecture, the perception
of rhythm or the sensate quality
of rhythms in architecture.
Especially the kind of architecture
that's cropped since the last 20,
15 years or so that's
very much influenced
by the digital technologies, where
there's a lot of like topology
and surface manipulation and such.
Let me just try something.
It's the images being
cropped a little bit.
Just try something.
Good. So, I'm just
going to run through a,
just to give you a background
of this kind of 15 to 20 years
of my own trajectory in architecture
associated with competition
and advanced digital design.
I'm going to just show you
productivity projects and then move
on to what's interesting
for us tonight.
So, this is a project that we
were invited to participate
in by the Museum of
Modern Art in New York.
They do this yearly program
called Young Architects Program,
and the PS1 in Queens.
And so, basically, I'm not going to
get too much into the architecture
because you guys did not
know that you were going
to get any architecture tonight.
So, I'm not going to force it
into you, but this is a project
where I think it's, for us it
was our first deliberate attempt
to really investigate a lot of
this idea of rhythm and rhythmicity
and rhythm perception
in the architecture.
And, of course, there's
their story, elevated tracks,
couple of blocks away from PS1,
and everybody that goes to PS1 has
to take this train, mostly.
So, this is an expense that you
really have when you're going to go
to these, to these parties that
are held every Saturday with music
and DJs and whatnot
at the open courtyards
that the PS1 Museum has in Queens.
And, so what you see
here is the top view,
a plan view of what's
grey is existing museum.
Everything that's white is the
open courtyards that there are
that you have to traverse
in order to get
from the street to the institution.
And, basically, where designing
is, it's a large installation slash
like large tent like structure
that will also host these
parties every weekend.
And, I just feel like I have
to go faster through this.
But, what you're seeing is, I think
this image is key in that the way,
it's about perception
because the way.
This was probably, it's
2008, but I was trying
to photograph the train
tracks very quickly
because there were
cops that didn't like.
You can imagine a guy in New York
taking photos of the train tracks
for a long time and the
structures from the [inaudible].
And, really, they grabbed
me, and they had me.
Lucky, they didn't
take away my photos,
but what I like about,
it's not that.
It's the fact that
they're rather big, right?
So, in order to capture that, I had
to do where there wasn't any kind
of technology such as
panorama or stitcher.
In the camera, I just
took many of these photos
and reconstructed like
[inaudible], right?
So, actually like that technique.
That was, I was using creatively
that technique all the time,
and the result is you don't get the
kind of smoothness or the continuity
that a real train tracks have.
But, you get this kind of faceted,
disjointed sense of continuity
which nevertheless provides the
sense that what you actually see,
your psyche associates this in
a way to which you perceive it.
But, it's completely
different, of course.
So, we decided to do our
project in the same manner.
It actually start with something,
because also because this
competition has a really low budget
for an architect, so and we were
very interested in curvature.
All that you see tonight is a lot
of curves and topological surfaces.
We wanted to convey that with,
but in very simple way
with faceted surfaces.
So, I tried to do the
same thing that was done
to the photographs [inaudible]
post operational procedure
to really start with that.
So, this project is at the
aggregation of certain series
of modules that they are rhythmical
but every single component
of that rhythm changes, right?
So, it's kind of modulative
rhythm, and every single,
there's a basic component for
the space that has, is repeated,
but no single element that form
part of a component is equal
because there's kind of this notion
of the overall movement, right?
So, it's about different
speeds in perception.
There's a part where you go through
and if there's a straight trajectory
from the street into the
museum, they just kind
of bypass this project or there's
another part where these kind
of lounge tools and
areas where there's much
of a lounge-y, like
slower perception.
That's kind of that space,
and there's all these cuts
that are produced by rupture
between the modules,
the [inaudible] project.
Through those cuts, you can
traverse these two realms.
So, that would be in a
real view of the project.
It latches on to an existing wall,
and that would, we didn't win.
We came in second.
Unfortunately, the winner only
is the one that gets to build it,
but so as I was saying,
this [inaudible] is kind
of like about the body.
So, we were obsessed with
the segmented animals
that have segmented bodies such
as the lobster which was really,
we were trying to see what kind
of intelligent logic is there
in the body of that animal that
we could appropriate or hack
onto into two kind of,
but these are these kind
of rather large architectural body
that you could have it, right?
So, this is actually the structures.
Underneath that, and anyways.
Moving on to the second architecture
project that I just only want
to throw in and background.
I'm not getting into it too much.
This is a project with it for
my hometown from Buenos Aires,
Argentina for the port of
Buenos Aires, and it's a project
for a large performing arts center.
Much larger than previous
project, right?
So, I'm going to upwards in scale
in the architectural projects,
and this one really was trying
to index look, first observe
and understand an index effects of
turbulence in liquids and see what
of that could we also
appropriate for architecture
and produce this project that
is set in a way that it's really
on the wharf on the main wharf that
gives access to the Puerto Madero,
the main port which is former
industrial port transforming to kind
of cultural office
area in Bueno Aires.
And, this is trying to set kind of
a first layer between the river,
the large river that Rio de la
Plata in Argentina and the port
where it's kind of like a
second horizon where this kind
of rhythmical progression
with distortion is set up.
And, in that sense, architecture
has a lot of inherent repetition
within just look at anything
in a [inaudible] from facades
to the modulation of that wall.
You know, it's really
anything has to be panelized
so [inaudible] components.
There's no single surface that
will be used, you know, that big.
So, taking on that given situation
and then using that as enhancing
that as an aesthetic and perceptual
device is what this projects
are doing.
And, again, I'm just bypassing
a lot and moving through it,
but it was also doing is
kind of offering itself as a,
more as a landscape
rather than as a building.
And, counterpoint existent
towers that kind
of punctuate the waterfront
of the city of Buenos Aires.
So, this becomes a very democratic,
very open surface that people can,
the rule from the project
is successful
for events and things like this.
So, the whole geometry
with all this pathways
and all these gangways is meant to
bring people into those surfaces.
And, in a way, it has several kinds.
This is very convoluted
rhythm of juxtaposed ramps
and whatnot that bring people in.
And then, there's very kind of
repetitive but with variation,
linear rhythm is the
[inaudible] horizon, right?
Then, this is kind of
drawings that we do,
and part of architectural stuff.
I mean, I call this, I mean I
naturally call this architecture.
I'm not sure that you
think these are,
this is what you normally
associate with architecture.
I don't see much of these in
the skyline in Washington.
I don't know.
Maybe soon.
So, moving on with this.
just for you to get a grasp that
what you will see next is sort
of coming from somewhere
and not from music, right?
So, that's kind of, that's the
reason I'm throwing it in today.
Of course, you know, in
our perception of rhythm,
I think goes hand in
hand with the notion
of sensuality and music in itself.
I mean, it's probably legacies,
I mean lots and lots of books
that speak about these beyond
my own capacity to look into,
but we find this idea of
rhythmic progressions also in many
in formations in nature such
as the strangler fig trees
which are everywhere in Florida.
They're fascinating and also
very time based processes
which can observe from the
roots of trees that grow
over existing trees and,
you know, kind of cohabitate
and [inaudible] fight
for [inaudible]
until the 200 years later.
Maybe, the host tree takes over and
exhausts the parasite tree, sorry,
takes over the host tree, and you
get this kind of open lattices
of depleted structures, right?
This one right here which are
absolutely wonderful and beautiful,
and it's kind of, I think I'm
giving up, I'm giving away a lot
by showing you these images
because then everything else,
you'd think it's just
replications of these, right?
And again, that's the only thing.
This is a trick, as gentleman
presented before had his own trick.
Our trick is only thing we do
is we been copying this stuff
in the workplace.
The other project, the last
project I'm showing which is this,
is the growing much more in scale.
This is a project for the, it's
in memorial for the victims
of the tsunami that happened
in Thailand a few years ago,
and it's 300 meters long.
It's an international competition,
and it's part of a
much larger jungle.
The project was on a site that had a
very small drainage up on the right.
It's [inaudible] that
went down about 25,
30 degrees down towards the beach.
And, what we did is we decided
in order to do a memorial
for such a dramatic event, to really
make a landscape project that was
like a collection of courtyards and
that these courtyards would line
up stringed by these kind
of [inaudible] channel
which [inaudible].
So, we made the presence
of water part
of the commemoration
of the dead, right?
So, and also what you see here
is many of those courtyards
and the green that you see is
the kind of interspatial spaces
between the courtyards where
[inaudible] colleges will grow
and new life will be cultivated.
So, any case, it's a product
that is, that has a lot to do
with repetition with, repetition
with variation played
out throughout.
There's no two single
instances that are the same
in which this courtyards
are laid out.
But, rather it's a collection
of multiple possible variations
out of a very simple initial unit
which is this courtyard here.
And then, ultimately has some.
This is the layout.
We have, you see, it's very long
pads, and there are some canopies
that hold over this courtyard.
And then, there are
those places where kind
of new natural growth
happens and going further
into the details is typically
how we proceed with, you know,
kind of excavating, give
much, much more detail.
These canopies are also large
pouches that collect water and kind
of [inaudible] throughout
the project.
So, it's kind of tubular.
Tubes that come out of
them that bring down water,
and they also become railings
and they also become pathfinding
elements throughout the project,
right?
So, this comes in effect
of synthesis in that way,
and in this project's the idea of
kind of second device that latches
onto its host and becomes
one with it, symbiotically.
It's present.
So, I'm just laying down
some of the tropes that were,
are constantly part of what
we do when we do architecture
that are there so that we kind of
can shift now and begin to look
at some of these things
that we have built recently.
So, that was growing in
skill, and I would have go
down in scale significantly.
This is a project that
was commissioned to us
for the Metropolitan Gallery in
one of these recent, very large,
three painting conferences
which has this,
some of these conferences
have an art section
and a fashion section and what not.
So, as an art section
slash architecture section
that we were invited, and with
it, we produced some structure
that I don't know yet what it is.
Honestly, I just don't
know that it has any use,
and it's also not a sculpture.
In, but I guess people
call it a sculpture.
It's mostly an exploration
of rhythmical was
in which you can embed
different kinds
of rhythms within other rhythms.
This project was done also
combining two digital fabrication
technologies, one is
the CNC milling,
and the other one is 3D printing
[inaudible] position modeling.
So, what you see here is
this larger kind of element.
Call it something, then receives
another layer of smaller rhythms
that are embedded within
some of these cavities.
In, throughout, I mean, this was
one of the first times that some
of those more conceptual and more
speculative architecture projects
have the chance to be explored
in, of course, very reduced scale.
But, the reason I wanted you to see
those architecture projects first is
because now the, exactly the
same techniques that are used
in 3D modeling, we use a software
called Maya from Autodesk.
And, the same way we think about
those projects, now, is, in a way,
it's a scaleless problem.
You can shift scales with
not difficulty at all,
even some DNA types of lines
and moves and surfaces used
for a master plan, you can
use for a door handle, right?
So, we definitely take advantage
of that, and, but it also,
along the process of doing that,
you discover effects of [inaudible]
and effects of machining and
programming how you want the machine
to cut certain materials.
Or, in the case of the
CNC milling machine,
the way the machine
operates is it moves
by sculpting away from
a solid piece.
In this case, we used a
high density foam for that.
Leaves a certain scoring
of the passes, and you can,
we can play around with that,
play with different kinds
of ways to produce texture.
So, there's I guess these
project was a way of, in a way,
I guess the first time that I showed
or that Scott saw these, he told me,
but that is a music instrument.
I said, "What the?"
I mean, I can't say that,
but you are absolutely right.
And, I think we were
communicating with Scott.
This was probably what,
three or more years ago?
There was a previous
version of these that where
that conversation took place.
And, then, at some point, he
came to our studio in Miami,
and he brought other things.
He just kind of brought like
a strange person that has,
I mean, he will play that.
Plays like a musician, but he also
has any number of other wizardry
with things that you wouldn't
think is coming from a musician.
But, it creates absolutely gorgeous
music out of something like this.
So, he saw the opportunities and
gets what was presently the project.
Inherent in the project was all
this kind of experimentation
with your kind of sensual
understanding of rhythm,
intuitive understanding of
rhythm which is coming from us.
And so, this project had
several different iterations.
The last one was kind of
more like a coffee table,
elevate about three or, I mean,
about four feet from the ground.
And so, we had an upper surface and
a downward surface and undercarriage
of sorts which sort
of were the same,
but then the undercarriage
developed the legs and was kind
of much more interesting
in that way.
And, in that case, again,
combining different,
just playing around with
different [inaudible] technologies,
the legs were treated [inaudible].
So, they were, in a way,
like the project was kind
of in still, on stilettos.
In the, in, when this was put
on that, in the exhibition,
everybody was asking,
"So, can I sit on it?"
No! I mean, are you crazy, and
can, "What can I do with it?"
I don't know.
I mean, it's there, right?
So, just feel it.
So, and that is a reason why I think
it's not clear to me what it is
because I'm not sure it is
something of that scale.
My mind maybe this is a large,
again, performing arts center
and you're underneath it, right,
and [inaudible] big columns
are supporting it, right?
So, in a way, architecture's all
of the stuff that we've been doing
that has to do with product design
and with objects is very impregnated
with our ways of thinking
and conceiving architecture.
And then, you can see how those
legs are really picking up on some
of the main lines of articulation
of the longitudinal rhythms
of this project and bring
down to much more detail.
The point that receives the
structural weight of a project
and transmits it to the ground.
Ultimately, this is what
the upper surface looks
like with all these sort
of nestle different scales
of rhythmical progressions.
And, this is probably my favorite
image where [inaudible] thinks that,
okay, 3D printing or CNC
[inaudible] is about pushing buttons
and transferring digital information
to physical constructions,
and it's much more a kind of
craft involved, handcraft.
Like, in this project, there was
a lot of selective sanding to kind
of be able to leave that certain
kind of scalloping in some parts,
in a different kind of scale
of scalloping in others.
To, so playing around with how
that would relate to the ultimate,
the uppermost layer of
repetitive 3D printer components.
So, there's a lot of investment
to obtain those effects,
and when we sent this from Miami
to New York, what we sent along
with it was a mirror surface
that would also reveal what
the undercarriage was like.
And, as you can see,
this is a rendering.
It's not a photo because, of course,
it arrived completely shattered.
So, we learned that it, you
know, have it cut locally.
You know, have a mirror cut locally.
Those were, so that was kind of,
kind of playing around with ideas
of symmetry, more than [inaudible].
And, like I said, this had
no, we had no use for it.
So, I just, I guess it was something
about, so definitely about the vibe.
That give you an idea of
how big or small that was.
And, for, I don't know
for which bodies or what.
You know, this is, what you're
seeing here is we played
around a lot with imagery
when thinking about projects,
and we were invited,
commissioned to do another project
for a gallery called Design Matters
in L.A. And, this was a great brief
that curators of that show
have which combine sci-fi,
architecture, and eroticism.
So, perfect.
Down our alley.
So, that seemed to be things
going back to Giger, right?
>> Right.
>> Eric Goldemberg: This
project, I think this,
the first one we really began to
interact with Scott in terms of,
I mean, long distance conversations
about the possibilities
of bringing sonic components to
the architectural installations
that we're doing around this time.
And, at the same time, the curator
asked us to sort of get some images
out so they could do their campaign
to raise funds for projects.
So, our first way we were developing
the actual thing that was going
to be built, we created this
kind of affect like imagery
that would tell the
story of this project.
So, I think these are the
possibility the best images about,
if not that one where I'm
on the [inaudible] project,
to tell about the relation,
the kind of prosthetics,
the way in which we begin to think
about in terms of prosthetics
when we think about music and
producing objects, instruments.
So, that's kind of a faade,
a view image of what the
structure we thought of making
which was ordinarily not made
of, not yet, at least not
yet which was basically
a, you know, speakers.
You know, typical Marshall style
of speaker is a vertical condition.
We thought of come tumbling down
the speaker and then holding that in
and showed them, and I showed
them height with a kind
of these typical structures
that you've seen us make before.
And, since those are tubular
and they look like roots,
we thought those were actually
the optimal opportunity
for wind instruments to be part of,
for a wind [inaudible] to be part
of this kind of complex instrument
which will include ultimately a DJ,
will include Scott sitting on this
and playing some strings
and blowing on it.
And, that's a top view of that,
so it'll have two types
of output for sound.
One would be kind of, kind
of multidirectional surface
of the grill of the speaker.
That won't be the directive
sounds coming out of those tubes.
And, we just went through
with that brief.
We took it whole heartedly.
[ Laughter ]
So, but, you know, we take
these things kind of really,
we think it's important to
kind of convey the sensations
of what you're working with in
that the architecture and the ways
in which the body could
potentially interact
with architecture are
absolutely interesting,
at least fascinating for us.
And, these are some of the typical
tests that we do at our office.
We have this MakerBot
machines and what not.
Also, have a lot of those
at FIU or we have a lab
where [inaudible] has
provided a machine
so every two students can share one.
We have like 38 machines or so.
So, it's great.
It's a luxury.
And so, these are smaller
prints, but then also playing
around these images that we were
asked to provide for, you know,
participation of the show.
We thought, okay.
We're going to keep playing
around with scale, with the scale
of the object, and something
which was large enough
to hold the upper bodies, you
know, we reduced it completely
and snugly applied it to this body.
And, that was kind of an intuition
of what could be possible
in terms of prosthetics.
It's kind of not yet trying to
produce an instrument in that way,
but we're just envisioning
something that we did later.
But, for that show, that is
the scale that was meant to be,
in that small details
and that speaker.
And, that's going to
further work on the project,
and the project gets refined.
And, at some point, you
begin to develop the logic
of how you're going to produce the
parts of it in a logical assembly.
I think that's still going on.
But, anyways, those are
more detailed images of it.
What you see, kind of translucent
surface on we're looking
from the top down, is the surface
of the speaker which is that.
And then, you see these higher
surface here is where the,
at the height of a
DJ cannot play there.
He's [inaudible], and
that's that project.
Now, this is really the first, in
effect, project where we were able
to collaborate with Scott, and
we also created, literally,
we created a guitar for it.
So, that's really the first product
of our collaboration with him.
But, this is a mural that was
created for, it's a sonic mural,
really, created for Miami
Beach Urban Studios.
There's a really cool gallery there,
and this is about 18
feet long or so.
And, what, the thought of this was
to create a piece that would, again,
it kind of hosts to the component
which is the music instrument.
The guitar would have two possible
positions, either on the left
or on the right, extreme left
or extreme right position
where they can actually be docked.
And, it's exactly the
negative form of the guitar
that receives it, and you see here.
There on the left side.
And, the musician, Scott, picks
it up and plays it and docks it
in any number of feedback
experiments can be played while the
guitar is in its place or played.
And, that is [inaudible].
So, it's probably one of my favorite
images ever from MONAD Studio
with Scott playing like this.
And, that guitar was actually
done with a CNC machine.
It's not a 3D printed guitar.
It's a milled guitar, and what
you're seeing here is separate the
unit which is the neck which Scott
typically fabricates the functional
component of the guitar.
And we work, you know, in
consultation and collaboration
with him to design the bodies
for guitars at our office.
But, this mural had
several sonic performances.
One of them, I'm going to play a
little bit of how that sounded,
is that those curves in the
variation and topographies
of the curves were done not
just an aesthetic device,
but also as something functionally
that it could be played
with these transducers.
So, through these, the
transducers are none other
than speakers without
the cone, right?
So, the transducers can reach, you
can, you know, measure any frequency
of any object, and
through the transducers,
you can get some sort
of reading of that.
And, in this case,
[inaudible] position [inaudible]
through the transducers
to the surfaces,
and according to how they were
gesturing over the surfaces
and finding, sometimes, some
deeper cavities on the surfaces.
And, this time will be amplified
in different ways, right?
Finding the cone or
not finding the cone
as they move through the cavities.
And you see some more images
of the guitar, and critically,
also these surfaces had scoring or
texture of the CNC milling machine.
And, that's really the very texture.
Some parts have heavily textured.
Some parts are much more
smooth, and that's by, you know,
by choice how you send
it as an after effect.
That's at the end, Scott and
the composers play all together.
They, what is interesting is
to, is that these surfaces
which are generated from
a kind of architectural,
from an architectural sensibility
are there to, now, for us,
for the first time for me at least,
that connection's not
inert, passive surface.
But, rather, this surface is able to
partake on the music effect, right?
So, there's a direct effect and
a direct, say, direct consequence
on some of the grooves and some of
the variation on these gestures.
But, what's interesting,
too, is if you were painting,
you would do gestures
of this size, right?
So, it's just kind of a scaler.
Very interesting scaler relationship
to me between the valley
of the scale of the gestures and
the real gestures that take place
when they move over it, right?
So, that's a detail that further
development of the guitar.
New, versions are, then, constantly
trying to perfect it, smoother body,
you know, different kind of neck.
This is a [inaudible] guitar.
Scott could tell you much more
about it, but it's something
that he created as an instrument
which has this kind of single string
that is a different version of it.
It's about basically it's
a travel basic or smaller.
But, so that's kind of that mural,
and I think this is probably the
most iconic of the instruments
that we've done thus far.
And, probably the reason
that we're here, ultimately.
And this, this is a two string
piezoelectric violin that we created
where this kind of
exaggerated size of it,
it is renders that we
created at the beginning.
Ultimately, it is much
smaller, but what we do
when we create these
instruments, I think this is part
that I'm really getting
excited about.
The more we do them, the more we
create [inaudible] other types
of instruments, is that it has a
lot to do, not only with posture
and understanding how musicians
need to play or how to,
how to best suit your habits,
different habits of
[inaudible] musician.
But, also, it does mean, in
working with these instruments,
what we're doing is we're
creating another body for it.
So, the guitars literally
have bodies only one
of these stringed instruments
have bodies.
But, what we're doing is
kind of a kind of volume
which surfaces are there to kind
of interface within the body
of the human and what's necessary
to perform with it, right?
So, for us, I think that's kind of
the more interesting opportunity
for the architectural exploration,
and as you can see, I mean,
I could tell you that this
is exactly, or not exactly,
but it has the same amount of
geometric information that was
to produce a very large performing
arts center except it's all
concentrated on something
that has this dimension.
Right? So, that's to me
the interesting point,
the interesting opportunity,
having done this 15 years
of those very large
projects which are way bigger
than what you can even
look at when you try it.
And then, all of a sudden, it's all
concentrated on one discrete device,
and that's more images
of the violin.
I'm going to just, I think that's
the right, this is the right image
to tell you where we
work in Florida, right?
It's kind of, it's very lush
presence of nature around it.
So, I think that the images speak
for themselves in terms
of the violin.
And, that we've done also a
one string piezoelectric cello,
[inaudible] cello who which is
there along with the violin.
And, I think the other part
that's really interesting is
that all this instruments for
us have [inaudible] relationship
with how they need to
interface with the body,
but about the other
components that are in it
which always is a process
of feedback with Scott.
We get a lot of back and forth
with him in terms of accommodating
for what is necessary in finding,
in his case, very creative ways
of alternative solutions to be
able to fit this [inaudible]
to be effective in terms
of the performance needs.
These are details of the violin.
We also created by the
time, we created like five
of these instruments at once last
April for an art show in New York,
and we also created for them
as another, different version
of what was then a
three dimensional,
two and a half dimensional mural.
This was a fully three-dimensional
spine slash rack of instruments
where five of these instruments
would be again mapped on latching on
and in the front, there are
these three stringed instruments,
the violin, the treble
bass guitar, and the cello.
On the back part, there
were two wind instruments,
one of which you saw an
image of Andrew's before.
This was built.
The pieces, again, is high
density foam structure done
with a CNC milling machine,
and all the instruments,
these five instruments, four
of them actually were created.
The fifth is in production, are
all 3D printed, are all 3D printed
with common MakerBot, you know,
nothing too sophisticated
in terms of printers.
And they played, and they,
we've been playing them
not only in Europe.
Then we, throughout the summer, we
went to Japan, to China, to Russia,
to Prague as well,
and Washington, right?
So, that's kind of an image
of the mapped-out instrument
onto the topology of a surface so
that there's no, there's nothing
to hold it other than
the form itself.
Sure. And, I just run
through the last images.
That's more on the guitar.
So, you get a sense of.
And, that's the cello.
I think that there's a lot
of interest in bringing
to these instruments the sensitivity
of those structures
that we found in nature.
And, in terms of that, I think
this is the most interesting one
because it's the largest one.
It's the one where the whole
way in which you're going
to hold this instrument
is not trying to map
out an existing standard instrument,
but it's we call it hornucopian.
But, it's actually a very large
[inaudible] around the body.
And, you saw it before.
That's Scott playing it.
And, I think that what is
interesting about it is really
in terms of scale, it's mapping
almost one to one the size
of the roots and the branches of
the trees that originated them
as triggers, image triggers.
I think that, the last thing
I'll show you is a couple
of other projects.
This is the fifth that was
not, it's not yet built.
We're still adjusting it.
It's getting more and
more interesting.
That's another one, and
[inaudible] in production.
And, this is being
printed as we speak
which is a six string electric
guitar, and it's the last instrument
that is in production right now.
And, I'm happy now to
let you hear Scott.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Anne McLean: Thank you so much.
That was interesting
to see how this evolved
out of architectural buildings,
rhythmicity, and into an instrument,
and it's exciting to see this
kind of a panel of people
who are doing this every day.
I really want to thank
you for coming.
I'm sorry about this, but
thank you to all our panelists,
and thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.